so here we are with type 3
hyperlipoproteinemia or familial
disparate elaborate anemia also known as
remnant removal disease or remnant
hyperlipidemia so here this is a this is
an autosomal dominant deficiency of a
protein II and that's kind of easy to
remember everything about just type 3
the three kind of looks like that right
Roman numeral just if you draw a line
you go like this or on the top you
basically got the letter e it's got
those three little prongs 1 2 3 so type
3e also the 3 kind of looks like a
backwards e right whatever anyway so a
protein e what is it important for it
allows for the clearance of chylomicron
remnants remnants and VLDL remnants
which are IDL's from the blood so what's
going on
if a PO E is deficient as far as the
pathophysiology goes if there's less
April protein E that means there's gonna
be less clearance of the chylomicron
remnants and IDL from the blood so
though those guys would have build up in
the blood so there will be increased
chylomicron remnants in the blood an
increased IDL in the blood basically
what's going on is that the chylomicron
remnants after the mature chylomicron
has the triglycerides cleaved into fatty
acids in glycerol we have the colomac
remember remnants with the a protein
that it needs to use to bind the apoE
receptor and subsequently be taken up
into the liver so if that apoE is not
there then this can't happen right this
can't bind and none of this will happen
right and won't be taken up ok and so
it'll just hang out and just be in the
blood all right and similarly vldls
after v LDLs or have their triglycerides
cleaved into fatty acids and glycerol we
have the the IDL as a product and that
IDL uses its a pro protein E and I use
that to bind vehicle you receptor there
and then it can be taken up but if that
ain't what protein is not there or if
it's efficient and this is not going to
be able to happen it's not gonna be
taken up and that idea will just remain
in the blood so those guys can build up
in the blood
and that's a key feature of this disease
you